and when you do something that stands
out is amazing you know and this did
family the three of them and that's
what's important uh in terms of this
filmmaker yeah
um and these actors they're astounding
the actual Supernatural plot to it uh
I remember of course and I remember the
ending very well but what I really think
is powerful in the film is really the
family Dynamic and what this kind of a
metaphor is this dinner sequence is a
remarkable sequences where she goes into
his room and it intercuts with him in in
flames
and the inter-cutting and how it's done
it just
wonderful filmmaking really uh
disturbing there's no doubt I mean it's
a horror film that way but it's more
than that it reminds me of the best of
the horror